5 23 on your friday morning what's cool
at school well before classes even start
how about just making sure you get there
in one piece
aaron breen from the road equity
alliance project wants to cut down on
the crazy traffic crowding of so many
kids getting dropped off at the same
time the less congestion around the
school the safer every child is she adds
not living within walking distance could
be a blessing in disguise if parents
would even park two or three blocks away
and walk their children in from there
what a big difference it would make the
bonus is you get to spend extra time
with your kid and how could that be bad
drivers can't let their guard down once
they're away from any flashing lights in
the immediate vicinity of any campus in
fact brain urges extra attention when
there might be kids on streets near
schools now you've got them crossing 45
mile an hour traffic instead of 25 mile
an hour traffic so you've got to pay
attention to those school crossing zones
as much as the actual school zone and
aaron suggests that while the
sentimental urge may be strong as you
said your kid off
maybe try being a little bit of a nag
instead in place of saying i love you as
you leave the house in the morning
remind them put your seatbelt on
make eye contact with drivers where's
your bike helmet
just that that one final thing that
could literally save their life
and you can't go wrong if the kids ends
up saying oh mom come on
but that is good advice and we want you
to stay with eight news now for complete
back-to-school coverage and if you know
something that's cool at school let us
know cool let's go under the community
tab at 8newsnow.com or just email
coolantschool 8newsnow.com